hallo
Ist schon am start
Und hier ist schon da
Ammo box camper hier bevor die leute anfangen max hat es dringend erinnert ich habe hier genug dabei
Er könnte mich trotzdem erinnern weil irgendwo müssen die channel points dahin
Erinnert mich ruhig habe ich eigentlich
alles
Ausgemacht
Ja kein blubber mehr kein color correction müsste eigentlich alles passen
ja setke
aber besser so
Wegen war ich gestern auch nicht
Schon mal die vm an
wollen major pain
Vor allem wer nervt nicht
Deswegen war ich gestern auch nicht
Dabei hätte ich gestern wieder harten
kreise klein machen müssen
Aber heute machen wir erst mal tag 2 und 3
auf code weil wir sind hinten dran wir sind mittlerweile schon bei tag 9 und erst tag 1 gemacht
Ja oder gut ich genug urlaub für kreise klein habe ich auch das stimmt wohl
Ja wir sind wir sind wir sind schon bei tag 9
Und wir machen heute tag 2 und 3 oder mal gucken mal gucken wie weit wir machen hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen davon ab
wie
Schwer das ganze ist
und
Ob ich mich so in der geistigen verfassung befinde das zu machen soll man einfach package updates weil arch Renault
bei ach so und ich habe ein
ein
Advent of code repo created
Da bruschen wir doch jetzt einfach mal den kram vom letzten mal rein bevor wir anfangen
Das war Tag 1, wenn ich richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ich glaube, das hat auch gestimmt.
Lass mal kurz schauen.
Tag 1 hatten wir gelöst, ne?
Kalender.
Ja.
Okay, Tag 1 haben wir gelöst.
Dann kommt heute Tag 2.
So, ich habe ein Repo angelegt.
Da pushen wir das gleich mal rein.
Advent Champ 2023.
Moment.
Ich muss das Repo umbenennen.
Ich bin ja schon...
Guck mal.
Ich hab mein Repo falsch genannt.
Ich hab mein Repo Advent of Code genannt.
Das ist aber eigentlich falsch.
Das müsste Advent Champ 2023 heißen.
Egal.
Komm, da weiß jemand...
Ups, warte mal.
Ich muss Headset entknoten.
Egal, geht schon.
So verknotet ist es gar nicht.
Da wissen die Leute wenigstens was mit anzufangen, okay?
Wahrscheinlich sogar besser, wenn das so heißt.
Ich push mal den Kram vom letzten Mal und dann machen wir heute Tag 2 und Tag 3.
Vielleicht, wie gesagt, ich weiß noch nicht genau, wie weit ich da komme.
Vielleicht machen wir auch nur Tag 2 und ich mach's in C-Sharp und in Bash oder irgendwie sowas.
Was ganz abgedreht ist.
Mal gucken, wie kompliziert das ist.
Ich hab schon ein bisschen gespickt.
Zumindest Teil 1 sieht relativ gut aus.
Easy aus.
Kobol.
Warum nicht gleich?
Wie heißt diese komische SAP-Programmiersprache?
A...
Irgendwas mit A am Anfang.
ABAP.
ABAP, genau.
Jaja.
Warum nicht gleich in ABAP, man?
Ich push den ganzen Kram.
Git, Remote.
Ach, guck mal, haben wir es noch.
Wobblors.
Advent of Code.
Git-Status, wir müssen mal kurz gucken.
Vielleicht sollten wir das umbenennen.
Weil bei mir heißt das 2023.
Das ist aber dumm.
Weil das...
Aber das hier machen wir mal zu.
Weil eigentlich...
Also ich sollte alles aus dem Repo da reinpushen.
Das heißt, ich würde eigentlich vorschlagen, wir nennen das mal um in...
Aber hier mal zu.
Wir benennen das mal um in...
Advent of Code.
Einfach nicht.
Event-Champ 2023.
Und dann machen wir hier einen Ordner für 2023.
Und da schieben wir das alles rein.
2023.
Wo ist mein Git-Ignore-File?
Irgendwo muss doch mein Git-Ignore-File noch sein.
Habe ich kein Git-Ignore-File?
Oder habe ich das hier drin?
Ich habe...
Ja, das ist PP-Gar, wenn ich kein Git-Ignore-File habe.
Dann...
Dann adde ich jetzt ja da auch alle Binarys.
Moment.
Hier, Git-Ignore.
Was?
Git-Ignore.
FFM-Pack gibt es nicht.
Aber dieser ganze Müll, der kommt da nicht mit.
Gut.
Moment.
Habe ich da...
Habe ich da schon Git-Repo?
Okay, ich hatte da schon Git-Repo angelegt anscheinend.
Ja gut, ist ja nicht schlimm.
Ist ja nicht schlimm.
Aber ich habe zu viel geedet.
Ich...
Das ist Blödsinn.
Was ich hier gemacht habe.
Wir entfernen...
Was?
Wir entfernen den Git...
Das Git-Verzeichnis nochmal.
Und sagen Git init.
Git add.
Git ignore.
Ach ja.
Ach ja, hatte ich doch schon ein Git-Ignore drin.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt.
So.
2023.
Git-Status.
Git add.
Ah, genau.
Der fügt jetzt nämlich wirklich nur...
Die...
Die Projekte...
Die Projekte und die Input-Dateien ein.
Dann ist das...
Dann ist das ganz gut.
Git commit.
Minus A, minus N.
Day one.
Shadows.
Git push origin.
Master.
Ach so.
Remote add.
Oh.
Mein Master-Branch heißt noch Master.
Gleich ganz Twitter-triggert.
So.
Okay, gut.
Passt.
Alles klar.
Hier ist der Krempel.
Gut.
Da haben wir die Vorbereitung abgeschlossen.
Ich habe heute auf Reddit ein Post empfohlen bekommen.
Wenn man die Reddit-App hat, gibt es ja immer...
Gibt es ja immer so Empfehlungen.
Und irgendwo hat einer einen News-Artikel gepostet.
Ich habe mir den aber noch nicht reingeguckt.
Vielleicht können wir uns den nachher zusammen angucken.
Ich habe noch nicht reingeguckt.
Irgendwie, dass Studien belegen, Homeoffice ist schlecht und wie die Unternehmen die Leute wieder ins Büro kriegen und sowas.
Aber ich habe in den Reddit-Kommentaren schon gelesen, dass dieser Artikel wohl rein etwas einseitig geschrieben ist.
Ja.
Ja, das Geile ist halt, die Leute denken jetzt auch noch, sie haben die Welt gerettet danach.
So nach dem Motto, ey, jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt gibt es keinen Rassismus, keine Diskriminierung mehr.
Weil der Brandschutz Main heißt.
Es ist alles weg.
Ja, aber es hindert keinen daran, einfach rauszugehen.
Man muss nicht auf die Arbeit gehen, um rauszugehen.
Das ist halt das Ding.
Ist bei mir auch so.
Eines der Hauptgründe, warum ich da hin bin, wo ich jetzt bin, ist, weil die natürlich lieber Geld und dass die Sachen an sich auch gut passen.
So, weil die eine gute Homeoffice-Regelung haben.
Aber nochmal hierzu.
Und ich verstehe diese Diskussion darum ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Es gibt ja wirklich Bereiche, wo man echt die Augen aufmachen muss und gucken, ey, da gibt es wirklich noch, wie soll man sagen, offenkundig große Missstände.
Dass es irgendjemand vor Mobbing oder Gedisse schützt, dass der Branch von Git, der standardmäßig angelegt wird in irgendeinem Repo, jetzt nicht mehr Master, sondern Main heißt.
Seriously, davon geht es keinem auf der Welt besser.
Außer, dass du dich sinnlos umgewöhnen musst.
Einfach.
Ja, bei mir ist es ähnlich.
Also, wir haben es mittlerweile so gemacht, dass wir ungefähr einmal die Woche da sind.
Jeder, jeder von uns ungefähr einmal die Woche da.
Wir versuchen das meistens so an dem Tag, wo Gruppenrunde ist, ein bisschen zu konzentrieren, dass man sich mal über den Weg läuft.
Aber ansonsten funktioniert das wunderbar.
Man muss echt nicht, also man kann, man kann gar nichts sagen.
Wir sind auch irgendwie nicht uninformierter.
Was wir im Homeoffice sind, ist sogar besser, weil wenn ein Teams einer grün ist, kannst du ihn in der Regel auch anrufen.
Nicht so, wie wenn die Leute irgendwie im Büro sind.
Du denkst, oh ja, ich geh mal kurz vorbei gucken, guckst bei dem rein, ist er gerade am Telefonieren, setzt sich 10 Minuten hin, was, bis der fertig ist.
Dann schwätzt du noch ein bisschen.
Total sinnlos.
Homeoffice ist viel besser.
Und wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wer eh die besten Homeoffice-Leute sind?
Das sind Leute, das habe ich ja schon tausendmal gesagt, auch ganz am Anfang, als die alle.
Moment, ich muss noch ein bisschen andere Musik machen.
Das ist ja immer der gleiche, gleiche Loop hier.
Ein bisschen wupp, wupp, wupp.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, jawoll.
Ja, das Beste sind tatsächlich Leute mit Online-Game-Erfahrung und am besten Leute mit Multiplayer-Online-Game-Erfahrung.
Sei es jetzt irgendwelche World of Warcraft Raider, Dark PvP-Leute oder einfach nur Clan-CS-Spieler oder sowas.
Leute, die wissen, wie man gescheit online mit anderen spricht.
Und gerade Leute, die ein bisschen, ich nenne es mal absichtlich.
Also einfach Competitive-Gaming-Erfahrung haben.
Die sind richtig gut, was Homeoffice angeht.
Die wissen, dass man in Teams nicht schreiben muss.
Sehr geehrter Herr Max, mit Erschrecken habe ich zur Kenntnis genommen, dass der Service seit 23.53 Uhr die Nicht-Verfügbarkeits-Seite anzeigt.
Bitte dringend prüfen und darüber den E-Mail-Verteiler informieren.
Mit freundlichen Grüßen, Ihr Anwendungsverantwortlicher.
Und wenn du solche Nachrichten per Teams kriegst, dann weißt du schon Bescheid.
Der Kerl, der hat oder die hat noch nie im Leben online irgendwas gemacht, gefühlt.
Kennt ihr auch so die, welche die halbe Romane schreiben über Teams?
Und denkst dir immer so, Alter, was ist mit euch los?
Die sollen mich einfach...
Und Leute mit Online-Game-Erfahrung, also gerade am Anfang von Corona und Homeoffice-Sachen hat man es gemerkt.
Ja, wenn das schon so anfängt, da weißt du Bescheid.
Aber gerade am...
Ohne Scheiß, gerade am Anfang hast du sofort gemerkt, wer Online-Game-Erfahrung hat.
Ja.
Du hast dann Leute in Teams, die haben geschrieben, moin, kannst du mal hier gucken.
So, fertig.
Kannst du mal hier gucken und haben gleich den Link gepostet.
Und da wusstest du Bescheid.
Und im Zweifelsfall hast du dann mal kurz auf Call gedrückt bei denen.
Hast dann hier, ich hab geguckt, probier mal aus, probier mal aus, ob es geht.
Zeig mal, wie das eigentlich aussieht.
Dann hat er schnell sein Screen geshared, gezeigt, aha, geht, passt wieder alles gut.
Also, du hast sofort gemerkt.
Oder auch, wenn man irgendwelche Besprechungen hat.
Also, in der Anfangszeit, irgendwelche Team-Meetings, wo dann...
Oh, kurz was dringen.
Auch am Anfang, irgendwelche Team-Meetings, wo dann die ganzen Leute, die ganzen Manager-Leute,
irgendwie sich überflüssig vorgekommen sind.
Und anstatt, dass man einfach über irgendwas reden konnte,
wurden dann irgendwie so komische Dinge eingeführt, wie,
ja, nachdem es jetzt ja für uns alle so schwierig ist und wir jetzt alle nur zu Hause sitzen,
machen wir jetzt...
Keine Ahnung, virtuell stoßen wir jetzt alle mal im Teams zusammen an.
Macht doch mal alle eure Kamera an und winkt euch zu.
Und wir haben alle da gesessen und gesagt, Alter, geh weg, Mensch.
Lass uns halt einfach unseren Kram machen, geh mir nicht auf den Sack.
Ihr kennt das vielleicht auch, ja.
Und der Witz war, die Leute so mit Online-Game-Erfahrung,
schon in Teams nebenbei geschrieben, so, lull, jetzt kommt das wieder.
So untereinander, wisst ihr.
Ja, sowas in der Richtung haben sie bei uns auch probiert, beim letzten Arbeitgeber.
Keine Ahnung, ich bin aber eh nie auf die Weihnachtsfeier gegangen.
Also auch nicht auf die digitale.
Und was du am Anfang von Homeoffice halt auch extrem gemerkt hast,
bei Leuten mit Online-Erfahrung, war, die wussten, wie man redet über Teams,
die wussten, wie man das Mikrofon sich nicht in den Popo stellt,
schiebt, bevor man irgendwie reinreden will.
Die wussten, dass es scheiße ist, wenn permanent im Hintergrund der Staubsauger läuft.
Die wussten einfach, wie man kurz, klar, knackig, ohne die anderen Leute abzufacken,
online kommuniziert.
Das waren auch die einzigen Leute, die wussten, dass sowas wie Push-to-Talk sinnvoll ist.
Ich meine, in Teams kannst du ja nicht so direkt Push-to-Talk machen,
aber du kannst quasi Mute-to-Mute machen.
Also du kannst...
In Teams machst du das Gegenteil von Push-to-Talk.
Du mutest dich, wenn du nichts zu sagen hast.
Das kommt im Prinzip aufs Gleiche raus, musst deinen Kopf drücken.
Und das haben nur Leute mit Online-Game-Erfahrung gecheckt.
Bei den anderen, bei den anderen hast du dann im Hintergrund irgendwie die Kinder schreien,
den Staubsauger am Start, den Fernseher.
Ja, Leute mit dem Mikrofon und sowas.
Giga-Cringe, ja.
Das waren auch so Dinger.
Aber mittlerweile, mittlerweile kriegen es die Leute hin.
Und was auch witzig war am Anfang, als diese ganze Homeoffice-Geschichte angefangen hat,
diese Suche nach Software dafür.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran, als am Anfang Zoom aufgekommen ist?
Niemand kannte Zoom bis daher und alle haben es an Zoom benutzt.
Und witzigerweise ging dann auch...
Moment.
Irgendwann ging dann die...
Diese...
Die Aktie von Zoom voll durch die Decke mit dem Unterschied,
es war damals noch gar nicht die Zoom-Aktie,
sondern irgendein anderes Unternehmen, das Zoom hieß.
Da haben die Leute random eine Zoom-Aktie gekauft, die mit dem Zoom gar nichts zu tun hatte.
Du bist einst...
Was?
Von deiner Belohnung verfolgt...
Ja, das ist wirklich Dice-Off.
Das ist auch so ein Feature, das hat auch keiner gebraucht.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich gehe davon aus, Twitch, die sind ja nicht blöd, ja.
Die haben das analysiert und haben festgestellt, dass das so Viewer-Engagement bringt,
wenn man sowas sharen kann.
Also dann, dann engaged mal.
Cringe-Choke wieder hier.
Chat-Ge...
Community-Ge...
Ja, ja, das ist gut.
Ich habe auch so ein paar Leute, wo ich weiß, also sowohl auf der alten Arbeit, als auch auf der aktuellen Arbeit,
wo ich auch weiß, dass sie online, sagen wir mal so, Online-Gaming-Erfahrungen haben.
Mit denen schreibe ich nebenbei auch immer ein bisschen, wenn irgendwas bescheuertes kommt.
Aus Rumänien.
Dort, wo ich jetzt arbeite, haben wir auch ein Off...
...Site, ich frag mich nicht, wie das genau heißt,
Entwicklerstudio...
...aus.
Es könnte auch...
Rumänien sein?
Ich bin mir da jetzt gar nicht sicher.
Aber irgendwo, irgendwo diese Ecke...
...ist das.
Falls später wieder Ragequit kommt.
Ach, das ist der Advent-of-Code-Erfinder.
Hast du, hast du schon das Video von ApoRed gesehen?
Im Moment, der hat wieder ein neues Video, nein, habe ich nicht.
Gibt's was Neues zum Insi-Modus, oder wie?
Wo hat er die denn jetzt?
Wo kommt der denn jetzt auf einmal her?
Ich dachte, Dubai ist das neue Meta.
Und außerdem, Moment, Moment.
War es nicht so, war es nicht so, dass der jetzt voll den krassen Trader...
...Trading-Hase macht?
Und da jetzt voll abgeht?
Aber, wie sagt man so schön?
Selbsterkenntnis ist der erste Weg zur Besserung.
Ob das lange hält, weiß man ja nicht.
3,6 Millionen Steuerschulden.
Du musst erstmal krass viel verdienen, dass du überhaupt so viel Steuerschulden machen kannst.
Und gut.
Ne, interessiert...
Also ich, ich, ich guck mir das nicht an.
Was sollen sie alle machen?
Ja.
Sein Steuerberater hat ihm gesagt, er muss teure...
Was? Okay, das ist...
Okay, ich kenne das Video nicht.
Aber solche Aussagen glaube ich eh immer nur so zur Hälfte.
Also mein Steuerberater hat mir noch nie gesagt, Max, du musst unbedingt dir jetzt, ähm...
...keine Ahnung...
...einen Rolex kaufen oder so.
So einfach random.
So, übrigens, Herr Max, wissen Sie, es wird mal langsam Zeit, sich ne, sich ne Rolex zu kaufen.
So, wa...warum?
Na, macht keinen Sinn.
Der Steuerberater sagt, der soll in die Gruppe, Gruppe kommen, ja.
Das sind die besten.
I-Ich muss mir kein Fiat kaufen, ich muss mir eigentlich als nächstes ein Jeep kaufen, dann...
...was ist da noch alles dabei?
Fiat Jeep.
Ich müsste mir quasi die komplette Fiat Champ
Autogruppe kaufen, um zu checken,
um zu testen, ob der Fiat Champ auch immer
funktioniert. Wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich glaube,
es gibt immer noch keine Issues, oder?
Ne, keine Issues.
Oh, da hat jemand was geupdatet.
15. Oktober. Nice.
Habe ich gar nicht gesehen, schon eine Weile her.
Hier gibt es immer noch keine Fehler, obviously.
So, also.
Ich zeige euch mal, wobei,
ich wollte gerade meinen Standardspruch
bringen, ich zeige euch mal, wo wir
stehen geblieben sind. Macht aber gar keinen Sinn, weil
wenn wir irgendwo stehen geblieben sind, wir waren mit Tag 1
fertig, aber Tag 2
und 3. Also.
Legen wir mal los.
Nein.
Sind sie nicht.
Das sind sie
definitiv nicht.
Ich habe den Namen der Stadt vergessen.
Wenn ich ihn höre, weiß ich es vielleicht wieder.
Es ist eine Stadt, die man nicht oft
hört. Habe ich vorher noch
nie gehört.
So. Also.
Dann gehen wir mal hier. Wir haben
2023. Tag 1.
Tag 2.
Aufgabe 1.
New Console.
Dann legen wir mal los. Machen das
auf und dann gucken wir uns die Aufgabe an.
Wie gesagt, ich habe
schon mal kurz gespickt.
Falsch.
Advent Champ.
Kurz gespickt.
Und das sah gar nicht so...
Ah. 0201
ist falsch. Es ist 0201.
Siehst du? Schon mal wieder verkackt hier.
Es ist nicht 0201.
Es ist MKD
021.
Weil es gibt ja nur 2 Aufgaben
am Tag.
New Console
Ups. Alter. Ich bin gerade
viel zu pepeger, irgendwie überhaupt
was zu bedienen.
Okay.
Der...
Ähm. Ryder ist pfeifertiger
als ich gedacht habe. Ryder macht jetzt einfach alle
Projekte auf. Nice. Soll mir auch recht
sein. Okay. Zack.
Zack. Advent of Code
2003.
01.
Alter. Heute
kann ich echt vergessen.
Run.
Hä?
Moment. Was zum...
Alter. Ich bin ja...
MKD. 01.
New Console.
Gut. Open.
Okay. Run.
Jetzt aber. Meine Güte. Schwere
Geburt. So. Dann schauen wir uns noch mal an,
was die Aufgabe von heute ist, würde ich sagen.
Mal gucken. Mal gucken.
Also mein Plan ist, dass wir heute Tag
2 und 3 machen. Oh shit.
So weit kommen wir heute nicht.
Ich muss mal schauen, wie lang
mein Brain heute durchhält. Ich bin immer noch
ein bisschen mitgenommen von gestern.
Deswegen vielleicht nur Tag 2.
Schauen wir mal. Oder vielleicht
auch gar nichts. Mal gucken. Also.
Hier sind wir stehen geblieben.
Advent of Code.
Wer das Ganze nicht kennt, ich werde es mal ganz kurz erklären.
Es gibt jedes Jahr
gibt es so einen
Weihnachtskalender. Quasi. Ich dachte
übrigens ursprünglich, dass es von GitHub kommt.
Das ist aber komplett falsch. Das kommt nicht von GitHub.
Das kommt von Erik Wassl.
Von was
punktet es eigentlich? Eine richtig gute Domain, oder?
Der erstellt
das jedes Jahr. Das ist auch, wo jemand
den Vortrag vorhin gepostet hat.
Und zwar
sind das 24, also wie so ein
Adventskalender, 24 Tage.
Jeden Tag wird was Neues
freigeschaltet. Und jeden Tag gibt es
zwei Aufgaben. Also ihr seht,
wir haben erst Tag 1 erledigt. Also richtig cringe.
Wir sind quasi die Hälfte
hinten dran. Ne, C++.
Heute nicht. Heute probiere ich,
wenn ich noch Zeit habe, die Aufgabe
in Bash zu machen. Mal gucken, ob wir es in Bash
hinkriegen. C++ habe ich das letzte Mal
nicht durchgehalten. So. Tag 1.
Tag 1 haben wir
umgesetzt.
Also nur, dass ihr euch ungefähr so
vorstellen könnt, was auf einen zukommt.
Das war alles für Tag
1, Aufgabe 1.
Und das hier war alles für Tag 1,
Aufgabe 2. Also die ganzen
Sachen sind immer relativ
übersichtlich. Also nur,
zum Beispiel, es gibt
einen randomizeden Input.
Was war jetzt hier für Tag 1? Es gibt
einen randomizeden Input. Und man sollte
rausfinden, was die erste und
letzte Zahl, wohlgemerkt Zahl,
nicht, dass nicht, wenn ihr 2 steht oder so,
die erste und letzte Zahl ist,
daraus eine zweistellige Zahl
machen und die dann am Ende zusammenrechnen.
Sieht dann, sah dann so aus
und
am Ende kam dann halt irgendwie raus,
keine Ahnung,
63.000 oder 59.000
oder irgendwie sowas. Also es ist relativ
übersichtlich. Mal gucken, wie das Ganze
heute aussieht. Die Aufgaben
schwanken übrigens auch in Schwierigkeit.
Also es ist nicht gesagt,
dass Tag 1
leichter ist als Tag
3 oder so, zwangsläufig.
Aber Aufgabe 2 ist
meistens schwerer als Aufgabe 1
an dem jeweiligen Tag.
Kein Regex? Tatsächlich kein
Regex? Nein.
Übrigens, auf die Idee bin ich
nicht gekommen, sondern der Chat.
Ich hab's auch am Anfang mit Regex gemacht.
Aber ich hab, ich hab
Teil 2 mit Regex
mit Regex gelöst. Hier, guck.
Oder Regex, wie die
coolen Leute sagen. Leute, seid
ihr, seid ihr eher der Regex
Aussprecher oder
der Regex?
Ich, ich bin ja für Regex.
Regex. Ich bin auch für Regex.
Nicht Regex.
Regex erinnert mich so an Webex.
Und Webex ist ganz grausame Videokonferenz
des, äh, Gedöns.
Muss jemand von euch manchmal
Webex benutzen?
Also mein Beileid schon mal, ja?
Von, von Cisco.
Das sag ich lustigerweise Cisco.
Aber es gibt auch Leute, die sagen
Zisco.
Webex ist richtig,
richtig, ähm,
heißt das die Mode nicht normalerweise anders?
So irgendwie,
egal, anscheinend nicht.
Ich will mir ein,
ich hab das Emote schon gesehen, aber unter anderem,
unter anderem, äh,
Emote-Begriff.
Ja,
es ist ja auch die Frage, ob es Jason
oder Jason heißt.
Ja, also wir, wir wissen ja, dass sogar der Jason-Erfinder der Meinung ist, dass es nicht Jason, Jason heißt, sondern Je-san, genau, genau.
I think the correct pronunciation is probably Je-san.
Je-san.
So, also, dann lasst uns mal angucken, bevor wir jetzt hier lange rumschwätzen, weil nachher weiß ich nicht, ob ich streamen soll, könnt, kann sich der Chat überlegen.
Nachher muss ich Chrysal-Kind weitermachen.
Ich muss sowohl in Alp mein, meine Sorgweite
ausrüsten, ähm,
in mit, mein Skal weiter ausrüsten,
theoretisch noch ein Charmy-Level und ein bisschen
PvP machen.
So, sind wir dann stehen geblieben.
Also,
Aufgabe Tag 2.
Wie immer, kann man den Anfang
erstmal vergessen. Der Anfang ist, der Anfang
ist immer Story.
Also die Story dieses Jahr ist,
wir sind, wir sind
von den Elfen beauftragt worden,
zu gucken, warum es
an 50 Stellen auf der Welt
nicht richtige
Schneeproduktion gibt.
Und dafür müssen wir die ganzen Aufgaben
lösen. Aber die Story,
wie bei MMOs, interessiert uns
nicht. Deswegen skippen wir die
Story einfach.
Okay, also.
As you walk,
the elf
shows you a small bag
and some cubes.
Okay, das ist immer noch Story.
Ah, ne, wobei,
wobei, okay. Es gibt verschiedene Würfel
mit den Farben Rot, Grün
und Blau.
Also, der Elf spielt wohl
irgendein Spiel mit uns. Okay.
Jedes Mal, wenn man das Spiel
spielt, versteckt er
irgendeine geheime, versteckt er eine geheime
Nummer von Würfeln
von jeder Farbe
in dem Sack.
Und das Ziel ist es,
das liest sich schon eklig.
Wenn ich solche, es gibt
zwei Möglichkeiten bei solchen Aufgaben immer.
Erste Möglichkeit ist,
es wird ganz eklig,
weil du verstehen musst, was eigentlich passiert
und das dann irgendwie nachbauen, oder
das ist alles nur Ablenkung,
Distraction vom eigentlichen Problem und hat
damit gar nichts zu tun.
Okay.
And your goal is to figure out
information about the number of cubes.
Okay.
Also, to get
information, once a bag
nee, once a bag has
been loaded with cubes, the elf will
reach
into the bag, grab a handful of random
cubes, show them to you
and then put them back in the
bag. Okay.
Und das macht er mehrfach pro Spiel.
Okay. Ich spiele mit dem elf
mehrere Spiele und
wir notieren uns quasi
von jedem Spiel,
was der elf für
Würfel gezogen
hat. Jedes Spiel,
okay, das war wirklich alles,
komplett unsinnige Zusatzinformationen.
Jetzt kommt eigentlich das Interessante.
Ja.
Okay.
Jedes Game in meinem Input
besteht aus einer ID.
Sieht man ja auch hier, also Game 1,
das ist dann im Endeffekt
die ID.
Und dann
followed by a semicolon separated list.
Quasi
von, nennen wir es mal von einzelnen
Spielzügen, könnte man glaube ich so
sagen. Also sprich,
im ersten Spiel hat der elf
quasi drei blaue, vier
rote, nee.
Doch.
Drei blaue, vier
rote, Würfel gezogen,
beim nächsten Schritt
einen roten, zwei grüne,
sechs blaue und beim dritten Schritt
nur zwei grüne. Okay.
Also das ist quasi unser Input.
Beziehungsweise den eigentlichen Input gibt's
dann hier.
Das ist ein bisschen mehr, dass man hier
nicht bruteforcen kann.
Also.
For example, okay, das ist ein Beispiel
Input, denn damit fangen wir mal an, da ist
nicht so viel. Das ist ein Beispiel
Input
von Spielen,
die ich mit dem elf
gespielt habe.
Okay, also das ist jetzt ein Beispiel. Im
ersten Spiel, also in dem hier,
wurde dreimal gezogen.
Ja, also, ne?
Erster Step,
zweiter Step,
dritter Step.
Ich muss bestimmt jetzt irgendwie sowas
ausrechnen, wie
viele Würfel noch übrig sind und so Zeug.
In, äh, in...
Okay, also,
three sets of cubes are revealed from the back. Ja, das haben wir
gesehen. Und dann wurden
sie wieder reingesteckt.
The first set is three blue,
drei blaue,
vier rote, second is
ein roter,
zwei grüne,
sechs blaue
und der dritte Step,
ist zwei grüne. Okay, das habe ich soweit gecheckt.
So, und jetzt will der elf
von uns wissen,
Which games
would have been possible
if the bag contained only
twelve red cubes, thirteen
green cubes, fourteen blue cubes?
Ey, ich kenne doch
die Regeln von dem Spiel überhaupt nicht. Was weiß ich?
Keine Ahnung, wo soll ich das
wissen? Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich
im Prinzip können
wir alles vergessen. Wir können das
hier alles vergessen.
Das ganze Gelaber können wir vergessen. Es ist vollkommen
egal, ähm, es ist vollkommen
egal, wie das Spiel funktioniert.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich vermute,
die wollen von
uns, dass man
die Anzahl
aller
Würfel pro Runde zählt
und dann guckt, ob die kleiner,
die, also, wir zählen,
wir zählen alle blaue Würfel, also
in dem Fall
neun und gucken, ob
es kleiner 14 ist.
Wir zählen alle roten Würfel,
also vier, fünf,
gucken, ob das kleiner
als zwölf ist
und so weiter.
Oh, Chat, ihr habt
recht. Stimmt, die stecken,
nach jeder Runde werden die Würfel ja zurück
in den Sack gesteckt. Also muss ich
nicht alles zusammenzählen, sondern nur gucken,
in welchem Step
die größte
Anzahl an Würfeln von
einer bestimmten Farbe gezogen wurde.
So, und alles, okay,
okay, das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so kompliziert,
glaube ich. Wir gehen das einfach
der Reihe nach durch. Wir nehmen die erste
Zeile, dann splitten
wir das auf, wir holen uns die
ID raus, wir
holen uns die
die Anzahl, wobei,
nö, noch nicht mal, wir holen uns nicht mal die ID
raus, wir brauchen die ID nicht.
Wir holen uns die
das, da machen wir wieder
Regex-Magic, wir holen uns quasi
von, von,
von jedem
jedes quasi
ja, Würfelpaar kann man das nicht nennen,
also jedes, jedes Würfel,
jeder Würfelzug holen wir
uns raus und gucken, was
ist die größte Anzahl an Zügen
von blauen Würfeln, die größte
Anzahl von roten Würfeln, also bei
Game 1 wäre das dann quasi,
das hier ist der erste Zug, das hier
der zweite, das, das der dritte.
So, und von jedem das höchste, hier werden
drei blaue gezogen, hier werden sechs blaue gezogen,
das heißt sechs blaue Würfel wären das,
hier werden vier rote gezogen, hier nur ein
rote, also vier und
zwei, also quasi sechs, vier,
zwei, also vier rot,
sechs blau, zwei grün
und jetzt muss ich gucken,
ist das kleiner,
quasi, ist
vier kleiner zwölf, ist
es, ist sechs
kleiner vierzehn ist es und zwei ist kleiner
dreizehn ist es auch, also wäre
das erste Spiel
okay.
So, und hier jetzt guck, hier zieht er
zum Beispiel fünfzehn blaue Würfel,
das wäre nicht möglich, weil es größer als
vierzehn ist.
Ja, ich glaube, so weit,
so gut.
Okay, jetzt kriegen wir das noch mal erklärt.
Game eins, zwei und
fünf sind possible, ja, das
eins possible haben wir schon gesehen, zwei
ist auch possible, alles deutlich
kleiner als zwölf, dreizehn oder
vierzehn. Game drei ist nicht
possible, weil zwanzig
rote Würfel gibt es nicht.
Ja, genau. Game
vier geht nicht, weil fünfzehn blaue
und game fünf
erzählen sie schon mal gar nichts zu, okay.
Ach, okay, if you add up
the IDs of the games, that would have
possible you get eight. Okay, also
wir brauchen die ID und
die ID müssen wir dann quasi eine Summe
drüber bilden.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich unser
Lösungs...
Code, vermutlich.
Ja, okay.
Ich glaube, ich habe es verstanden.
Chat, habt ihr es auch verstanden?
Ich glaube, so weit passt.
Oh.
Excellent, excellent, excellent.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Ohoho.
Ich würde vorschlagen, wir...
Ne, komm, fang gleich mit dem ganzen an,
Pütz.
Du würdest das mit Async machen.
Hä?
Irgendwie war ich halt Async, jetzt irgendwas
damit zu tun.
Du meinst, die Zeilen
parallel durchsuchen und nicht
nacheinander?
Oder was?
So, äh, Quatsch.
Wir brauchen hier eine Datei, nochmal.
Input.txt
Machen wir wieder das gleiche.
Wie das letzte Mal, letzte Zeile
weg.
100 Zeilen haben wir mit Games
drin. Okay.
Dann machen wir doch mal,
das gleiche, wie letztes Mal.
Das können wir uns kurz copy-pasten.
Also, Input.
Gucken wir mal, ob alles funktioniert.
For each.
Line in Input.
Line.
Schauen wir mal, ob es funzt, ob alles läuft.
Yep. Funzt.
Das ist nicht
Kreiselcrined. Nein.
Kreiselcrined, wenn ihr wollt, können wir heute Abend wieder machen.
Ich muss, ich muss mir noch
ein Shummy leveln, ich muss noch mein Scalde fertig ausrüsten,
und ich muss noch meine Hexe
ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ähm,
ich muss noch Epic machen mit der Hexe,
weil 50 ist die, die ist schon 50.
Und, ähm, dann muss ich
noch ein bisschen PvP machen. Bäschen,
alter, bäschen. Okay.
So, konzentrieren.
Was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Würde mit Async machen,
wegen IoT, alles klar.
Ja.
Und wann machst du Big Data?
Und wann wird diagonal skaliert,
um die Synergieeffekte zu nutzen?
Und wann gibt's
die passende Blockchain-Lösung, genau.
Hahaha.
Ich sehe,
ich sehe, der Chat, der Chat
ist im Business-Enterprise-Modus
gerade schon wieder.
Man könnte, man könnte quasi sagen,
der Chat ist im Stonks-Modus.
Die Leute nicht zu sehr mit technischen Details
verwirren. Das, weil,
wir wissen, also wenn wir eins aus YouTube
und Community-Gruppe gelernt haben, ist es,
dass man eigentlich nichts können muss,
man braucht nur das richtige Mindset.
Der Rest geht von alleine.
Also, ihr müsst nicht programmieren können,
ihr müsst euch mit Technik nicht auskennen,
ihr braucht einfach nur das richtige Mindset.
Das wird, das ist quasi
das richtige Grindset-Mindset,
sozusagen.
Das richtige Grindset haben wir nachher auch.
Da werden wir eine Runde Kreise
grinden wieder. So, einmal jetzt Chat.
Ruhig jetzt, hier, mit
Business-Enterprise-Stells.
Ja, fünfmal musst du aufstehen.
Und du musst dir die Biografie von
Elon Musk kaufen, dass du,
dass du
dann irgendwie so tun kannst, wie
ich bin der neue Elon Musk für
irgendeine hessischen
Drei-Mann-Klitsche, so.
Und nicht nur einmal.
Ja. Okay.
Also, auf geht's.
Was, was
wollen die jetzt, was wollen die jetzt von uns?
Community-Gem.
Was wollen die jetzt von uns?
So.
Wir machen das jetzt mal so hier.
Wir kopieren uns das mal raus, dass ich mir das merken kann,
wo, wo die Limits sind.
Also.
Wir bekommen pro Zeile,
dass, ich will sagen,
der erste Step ist,
in jeder Zeile
rauszuparsen,
was
die höchste Anzahl an Würfel
ist.
Dazu machen wir erstmal RegalX Magic.
Gucken, ob das,
gucken, ob mir da, ob mir da
ein guter RegalX für einfällt.
Also.
RegalX, wir suchen etwas, das
besteht aus
Digits, Leerzeichen
und dann eine Farbe.
Gut, das ist eigentlich relativ einfach.
Digit, Leerzeichen und dann irgendeine
Farbe. Red, Green, Blue.
Ne.
Red, Blue, Green. Es ist egal, die Reihenfolge.
Aber ich finde Red, Blue, Green
kann ich irgendwie besser merken.
So.
So, das ist im Prinzip...
Aha, Moment, Error.
Wer sieht den Fehler in meinem RegalX Chatge?
Wer ist...
Okay, ihr wollt Green zuerst, meinetwegen.
Was ist der Fehler in meinem RegalX?
Ja, doch, leider RegalX, müssen wir jetzt durch.
Ihr kennt ja den alten Spruch,
willst du ein Problem mit RegalX lösen,
dann hast du zwei Probleme.
Richtig, Theo.
Red kann mehr als 1 sein,
weil es kann ja durchaus auf 15 gezogen werden.
Richtig.
Aber es kommt auf jeden Fall
immer ein Leerzeichen.
Wir können sogar ganz high IQ sein
und White Space Characters
benutzen an der Stelle.
Massive.
Alles klar, so.
RegalX, Matches,
Line.
Schauen wir mal, was da rauskommt.
Äh, Chat.
Wie viele Matches
haben wir denn hier jetzt?
Ah, einige.
Das scheint schon mal
halbwegs zu funktionieren. Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment, ich brauche noch
eine Gruppe um die Digits,
damit ich darauf zugreifen kann später.
Okay.
Das sollte doch jetzt so funzen.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, was mein RegalX
geregalxt hat. Ich habe noch eine andere Idee.
Zum RegalX Buster.
Was immer ziemlich nice ist.
Nehmen wir mal die Zeile hier zum Beispiel.
RegalX Lab.
Kann man zum Beispiel hier
seinen Input reinkopieren.
Das meinte ich übrigens auch, RegalX 101.
Das ist das, was ich gesucht habe.
Hieß das früher nicht mal RegalX Lab?
Das ist das, was ich auch gesucht habe.
So.
Und jetzt mal unseren
RegalX reinkopieren.
Und man sieht,
das funktioniert.
Wir matchen
Digits
beliebig viele.
Gefolgt von White Spaces.
Gefolgt von Rot
oder Grün oder Blau.
Also man sieht auch hier, wird gematcht.
Match 1,
Match 2, Match 3
bis Match 18.
Das scheint zu funktionieren.
Vielleicht kann
ich auch noch die ID matchen.
Das wäre natürlich super
Massive Premium.
Wenn wir die ID da noch irgendwie, sagen wir mal
Zeilen beginnt mit Game.
Geht dann weiter mit
ähm
Digit
Doppelpunkt, Leerzeichen.
Ach nee.
Das funktioniert jetzt ja an der Stelle natürlich nicht mehr.
Weil das dann alles in der richtigen
Reihenfolge kommen muss und nicht
mehrfach drinne vorkommen kann.
Um das zu fixen
könnte man
das jetzt theoretisch klammern.
Und nen
Oder davor machen.
Oh fuck, Alter.
Leute, ich glaub, ich glaub es funzt.
Ich glaube HighIQ
Regex hat zugeschlagen hier.
Alles klar.
Warum ist Regex immer so
unleserlich, Mann?
Okay, jetzt lasst uns mal kurz
checken, ob das Sinn ergibt.
Das heißt Match 0.
Match 0 sollte eigentlich immer die
ID sein.
Äh, Moment, Moment.
Nein, nicht Match 0.
Ja doch.
Oh fuck.
Ach, Kroop.
Kroop, okay.
Match 0. Und was ist Match 1?
Ah ja, das.
Aber, aber
ich hab doch das hier auch gecaptured.
Jetzt.
Oh fuck.
Okay, das.
Und da hab ich jetzt Kroops.
Fünf.
Okay.
Hey, funzt, nice, guck mal.
Okay, Match 0.
Das ist egal, ob wir das auch so gepasst hätten.
So, das hier ist die ID.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe,
dass heute die Zeilen nicht gefaked
Also, letztes Mal war das Problem,
dass im Input Syntaxfehler drin waren.
Ich hoffe, diesmal sind keine Syntaxfehler
drin, weil wenn absichtliche Syntaxfehler
eingebaut wurden, bin ich ziemlich, ziemlich
gearscht, ja.
Okay, das ist die ID.
Pass.
Das ist die ID.
So, dann geht's weiter.
Dann geht's weiter
mit Matches.
So, und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, ähm.
Okay. Oh ne, jetzt brauch ich eine zweite
Schleife.
Haha, wahrscheinlich hätte ich es echt einfacher
von Hand gepasst, Alter.
Ähm, Matches.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal .NET Magic benutzen.
Wir wollen alles
ähm, von 1 bis Ende.
Oh ne, wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Ne, Moment.
Bin verwirrt. Wie war, wie war da die richtige Syntax
für nochmal? 0
gleich Matches.
Oh, das Funst, das weiß ich.
Konnte man, konnte man nicht sagen 1 bis Ende?
Ne,
anscheinend nicht. Ähm, okay.
C Sharp Range Syntax.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Ranges.
Beispiel Microsoft, Beispiel
please. Doch.
Ne, ne, ich hab mehrere Matches.
Äh, das Funst
irgendwie nicht.
To Array, bam. Jawoll, nice.
Ihr habt recht,
das geht nur auf Arrays.
Also, Matches
von 1 bis
weil das erste
wollen wir ja nicht mehr.
Das erste ist ja unsere
ID. Ähm, hier
Match.
Oh, Match. Jetzt gucken wir mal, was das
ausspuckt. Wir, wir, wir breaken mal
nach der ersten Zeile, dass ich's irgendwie checke.
Okay,
19 Blue, 12 Red, 19
Neu...
Sicher?
Tatsächlich. Das scheint zu
stimmen, Leute.
19 Blue, 12 Red, 19 Blue, 2
Green. Ja,
ich denke, ich denke, dass, ich denke,
das stimmt. Guck mal hier.
Ja, 19
Blue, 12 Red, 19
Blue, 2 Green,
1 Red, 13 Red,
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, Regex Magic hat gesiegt.
So, und jetzt müssen wir mal
gucken, wie wir
dort...
Erkennst du denn die Semikolons?
Nö, muss ich auch gar nicht.
Es ist,
das ist eigentlich egal an der Stelle.
Ich muss einfach nur rechnen, was die höchste Anzahl
an Blauen, die höchste Anzahl
an Grünen und die höchste Anzahl an Roten ist.
Es ist, glaube ich,
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, vielleicht brauchen wir das für
Step 2,
ja, die Aufgabe ist wieder richtig
übertrieben geschrieben, so,
damit es da ganz viele Informationen gibt, die dich
eigentlich gar nicht interessieren müssen.
Okay,
jetzt muss ich
was machen?
Jetzt muss ich den ganzen Krempel zusammenzählen,
korrekt? Also,
ich habe jetzt ein Regex,
warte mal, in dem
Regex, da habe ich jetzt Groups.
Und was steht in welchen
Groups drin? Was steht in Group 1
drin? Das komplette
in Group 2
nichts.
Und in Group 3?
Moment, in Group 3 stehen jetzt die
und in Group 4? Okay,
whatever, whatever,
Gruppe 3 und 4 ist es.
Was macht
Regex?
Okay, das ist unglaublich schwierig
in zwei Sätzen zu erklären, was Regex macht.
Mit Regex
kannst du Text untersuchen, ob es
gewissen, einer gewissen
...
Logik.
Wie kann man Regex in zwei
Sätzen erklären, Leute?
Mit Regex kannst du Textinput
überprüfen, ob es einem gewissen Muster
folgt.
Ich glaube, das ist das kürzeste und knackigste,
was mir so einfällt.
Du kannst gucken,
ob dein Textinput einem bestimmten
Muster entspricht.
Und diese Syntax,
um dieses Muster anzugeben,
das ist allgemein das,
was man
unter Regex versteht.
Also zum Beispiel, was der Regex hier oben
bedeutet ist,
am Anfang der Zeile übrigens
der ...
Am Anfang der Zeile
muss das Wort
Game stehen.
Leerzeichen, danach
muss eine beliebige Zahl kommen,
beliebig oft hintereinander,
gefolgt von einem Doppelpunkt.
Also wenn du dir hier den Input anguckst,
siehst du auch, so ist die Zeile aufgebaut.
Das heißt, das Match steht drauf.
Der Start mit Game,
Leerzeichen,
und dann kommt eine Zahl,
beliebig oft, weil es muss ja auch sowas wie 10
und nicht nur 1 gematcht werden.
Wenn ich das Plus hier weglassen würde,
dann würde der immer nur hier eine 1,
dann würde es nicht mehr matchen.
Man muss ihm sagen, okay,
es kann eine beliebige Zahl kommen,
beliebig oft hintereinander.
Allerdings der Unterschied
zwischen Plus und Sternchen,
chat, pfeifert Regex-Kenner.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wer es weiß.
Was wäre in dem Fall der Unterschied
zwischen Sternchen und Plus?
D gilt für digit,
genau, also eine Zahl im Endeffekt.
Ich glaube, ich habe sogar eine Hilfe,
wenn ich hier drüber bewege.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ja, korrekt.
Der Chat
weiß Bescheid. Siehste?
Communityge high IQ
heute. Richtig.
Der Unterschied ist, Plus
bedeutet, es muss mindestens
einmal vorkommen, beliebig oft.
Also 1 bis
beliebig oft.
Genau, man könnte das auch noch mit
geschweiften Klammern dahinter machen.
Wobei ich das eigentlich nur benutze
für, wenn ich sagen will,
1 bis 3 oder so.
Also bei IPs zum Beispiel.
Plus sagt, es muss
quasi 1
bis
unendlich vorkommen.
Sternchen würde sagen,
0 bis unendlich.
Das heißt, Sternchen
heißt auch immer, es wäre
erlaubt, dass nichts da
steht an der Stelle.
Und Sternchen machen in der Regel
eure Regexe kaputt.
Nicht, dass ich das nicht auch an jeder Ecke verwenden würde.
Aber meistens ist das so besser.
So, also auf geht's.
Group 3 ist
der Count.
Und Group 4
und Group 4 ist die Color, oder?
Nichts ist richtig.
Group 4 ist die Color.
War Color gleich.
So.
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt
passt oder ob es irgendwo crasht.
Ich spüre es einfach mal aus, wenn es nicht crasht.
Okay, gut.
Ich sollte mal das Break ausmachen.
So, mal gucken, ob es irgendwo crasht.
Gut, gut.
Scheint zumindest alles syntaktisch
richtig zu sein.
Dann würde ich sagen, wir machen es jetzt
ein bisschen
advanceder. Und zwar, wir machen dann
eine Link Expression draus.
Und zwar sagen wir
Matches von 1 bis zum letzten
Element
Select Match
und das hier
lassen wir das mal raus.
So, das transformieren
wir in ein neues
Objekt.
Und zwar mit
äh
M ist es dann nur noch?
Das transformieren
wir in ein neues Objekt
mit, nennen wir das mal
hier irgendwie Result.
Mit einer Variable
Color, eine Variable Color.
Dann, oh fuck, wie
macht man das denn jetzt?
Moment, Moment.
Freehead. Du kannst den
Groups auch Namen geben. Ja, das geht auch irgendwie.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, du kannst
irgendwie, irgendwie so, so irgendwie
kann man Namen machen, aber
weiß ich aus dem Kopf.
Wir haben, das haben wir letztes Mal ja probiert.
In C Sharp hat sich tatsächlich
vieles getan. Also das, was du 2017
programmiert hast, geht heute auch noch.
Aber sie haben einige neue Sachen drinne schon.
Ja, du kannst zum Beispiel
jetzt sowas hier machen. Record
Cag
und da sagst du Int A
Int B
Das ist so eines der
neueren Aushänge Features, was Microsoft
immer, immer wieder betont
und bewirbt. So, und wenn du sowas
hier hast und das ausgibst,
dann kannst
du es quasi so anlegen und wenn du es ausgibst,
ist auch quasi überschrieben,
dass du eine gescheite Konsolenausgabe kriegst
und es ist
auch überschrieben equals,
dass das und das gleich ist.
Weil bei Klassen wäre das ja nicht,
also bei normalen Reference Types
wäre das ja nicht so.
Sag ich ganz, ganz sinnig, was sie
da gebaut haben. Aber nicht alle Features,
aber nicht alle Features sind nice. Da sind
auch ein paar echt bisschen,
ich weiß nicht, unfertige
beziehungsweise, wie soll ich sagen,
nicht zu Ende gedacht
dabei gewesen die letzten Jahre.
Genau, und außerdem, dass man ein Top Level,
da habe ich gar nicht mehr dran gedacht, genau,
dass man ein Top Level Programm schreiben kann
ohne Program Main
ist auch relativ neu.
Wobei man dazu sagen muss, unter der
Haube ist es immer noch das gleiche, nur dass
der Compiler für dich das quasi
das Main
drumherum generiert.
So, also.
Wir müssen jetzt, nur dass ich, Chat,
nur dass ich jetzt weiter durchblicke.
Wir haben uns jetzt rausgeholt,
die Anzahl an
Würfeln pro
Step in welcher Farbe.
So.
So, und das Count,
Count sollte by the way
auch ein Int sein.
Hallo? Achso.
Cool.
Int Parse,
das muss er wahrscheinlich an ToString machen.
So.
Jetzt haben wir das.
Ich bin mir jetzt etwas unschlüssig.
Gibt es jetzt Sinn, was ich hier gemacht habe?
Okay, bis jetzt
scheint es zu funktionieren.
So, also. Okay, Link Magic,
Leute, Link Magic.
Wir haben alle Würfel
pro Step und die Anzahl. Das heißt,
jetzt müssen wir raussuchen,
was,
jetzt gucken wir nochmal den Input an,
was die höchste
Anzahl von
Würfeln pro Farbe pro
ja, pro Zeile,
pro Game ist.
Also in dem Fall hier
19,
13,
2 müsste dann da rauskommen.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Könnten wir,
ich meine,
die einfachste Sache wäre
zu sagen
irgendwie
Red gleich Result
Wear
was ist das?
Ja, Würfel.
Wear Color
gleich gleich Red
wobei das bestimmt noch
einfacher geht.
Und dann Max
Counts.
So, und da müsste ich jetzt die höchste Anzahl
von roten Würfeln immer rauskriegen.
Aber das ist doof. Das ist so
doppelt gemoppelt alles.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Aber funktionieren würde es
so höchstwahrscheinlich.
Ah, Chat. Ich habe eine Idee.
Ich habe eine Idee. Pass mal auf.
Six Head Mode.
Ich hoffe das funktioniert.
Pass mal auf.
Group by
ähm
Group by Color
Ich muss das gerade nochmal ausgeben,
sonst checke ich es wieder nicht.
Ach, das checkt er mal wieder.
Nice.
Ok, Group by
Color
Von der Idee her
kommt jetzt da so eine Art
Dictionary Hash Map raus.
Ne, kommt nicht.
Da kommt
jetzt eine lange Liste raus mit
Moment, was?
Ich muss mal kurz checken, was kommt da jetzt?
Result, Count,
Length, Count.
Kommt jetzt da 3 raus oder mehr?
3. Ok.
Dann ergibt es tatsächlich Sinn.
Gibt es auch
Group by
Ja, ja, habe ich da hier.
Ne, sowas.
Das ist ja kein SQL.
So, wartet mal. Group by Color
Und jetzt
kann ich jetzt sowas sagen wie
Also das benutze ich auch sehr selten.
Kann ich jetzt sowas sagen?
Ok, mal skippen.
Max by? Oh, das ist auch gut.
Max
by?
Ne.
Ah!
The fuck!
Moment.
Wie ist das jetzt? Was habe ich denn hier
überhaupt? Key.
Ach, Value ist
das hier. Ok.
Ah ja, das würde funktionieren, aber das ist ja nicht das, was
ich haben will.
Das ist ja nicht das, was
Ne, Max, das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Ich weiß, was ich haben will. Ich will
Dictionary haben.
To Dictionary.
Und da will ich jetzt haben für den Key
will ich den Key benutzen
von der Group
und für den Value
für den Value
will ich
Max
Aber Max
was?
Moment, das ist ja auch eine Group.
Das ist ja G. Count.
Heute machen wir ja kein C++.
Das kann man vergessen.
Oh, ja.
Ergibt das Sinn?
Ergibt das in irgendeiner Art und Weise Sinn?
Key
und dann Max
als
Ich hoffe, das
funktioniert, Leute. Ich bin mir jetzt echt
unschlüssig gerade. Also wenn es
funktioniert, sollte es jetzt ein Dictionary
gegeben haben mit Red
mit Blue
und mit Green, ok?
Es crasht nicht.
Ich würde mal fast
vermuten, dass das
funktioniert so.
Vermutlich.
Kann mal kurz jucken.
Das sieht doch eigentlich
jetzt ganz brauchbar aus
an der Stelle.
So, jetzt haben wir einen Dictionary.
Kann .NET 7 gegen C Sharp 12
kompilieren?
Ich bin mir ehrlich gerade nicht sicher,
wie genau die Abhängigkeit ist.
Also du kannst teilweise
neueren Code kompilieren,
sogar noch gegen .NET Framework.
Aber wahrscheinlich
ist es echt so, es hängt hauptsächlich davon ab,
was für Features du benutzt.
Aber solange man .NET Core verwendet,
macht es ja eigentlich kaum den Sinn,
was anderes als die neueste .NET Core Version
zu, also es heißt ja nicht mehr .NET Core,
die neueste .NET Version zu benutzen.
Wenn man natürlich noch auf Framework hängt, dann
hat man vielleicht noch mehr Probleme.
So, Chat, das ist doch
fast, das ist doch fast das,
was wir haben wollen, oder?
Fragezeichen?
Korrekt, Fragezeichen?
Also, das bedeutet
doch im Endeffekt, jetzt wollen wir gucken,
if,
so, red,
maximum red, größer,
ähm,
größer
gleich 12,
und, und,
result
blue, größer gleich,
ähm,
ja, machen wir green,
größer gleich 13,
Moment,
größer gleich?
Ne, kleiner
gleich, kleiner,
kleiner gleich?
Größer,
kleiner gleich, ne, wir wollen
gucken, ob das, ob das kleiner
ist, als die Anzahl,
aber wir wollen ja wissen, ob quasi
der Zug möglich wäre,
mit einer maximalen Anzahl von diesen Würfeln,
ok, kleiner gleich,
und dann als letztes,
result blue, kleiner
gleich 14,
keck, so, gucken wir, ob das doch noch
ohne zu crashen funktioniert, ok,
und jetzt haben wir
die ID von dem Kram,
eva, cnt
gleich 0,
cnt
plus gleich
ID, äh,
nicht ID, count,
so,
632,
kommt da angeblich raus,
ich bin mal gespannt, ob das stimmt,
wobei ich ja sagen würde,
das ist auf jeden Fall noch nicht enterprisey
genug, gell,
die Aufgabe, nicht, nicht
enterprise genug,
ich würd sagen, wir sind, wir sind tatsächlich mal
ordentlich, ich hab, ich hab ne Idee,
ok, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was wir machen?
Wir machen das, weil das ist, das
könntest du eins zu eins so in fast jeder
Programmiersprache basteln,
also, wenn ich jetzt hier plus plus,
da ist sowas hier natürlich schwierig,
wobei, ganz ehrlich, diese Link-Geschichte,
wenn ich das in ne anderen Sprache,
wenn ich das hier in ne andere Sprache übersetzen würde,
würde es wahrscheinlich trotzdem wieder ganz anders aussehen,
aber,
wollen wir, können wir überprüfen erstmal,
ob das stimmt, was hier jetzt rauskommt,
warte mal, rot,
kleiner 12, 3,
grün,
kleiner 13, und 14,
kleiner, äh, und blue,
kleiner 14, scheint zu stimmen, ok, guck,
gucken wir mal, Chat, Abstimmung, Sekunde,
vote,
äh, ne, nicht vote, äh,
prediction,
start prediction,
wird das Ergebnis stimmen, ja, nein,
start prediction, ja,
also, ich werde
das gleich in die Seite reinhauen,
ach ja, und falls ihr denkt,
bei euch war das, war die gleiche
Zahl als Ergebnis, das kann nicht sein,
weil der Input randomized ist,
also, ihr könnt anhand von meiner Zahl,
und selbst wenn ihr es im Vorfeld gemacht habt, nicht ableiten,
ob das stimmt oder nicht stimmt,
nur die LTS, alle, jede zweite
Version ist da, ist, ist,
ist da LTS, oder,
das heißt, jetzt kam 8,
8, ist 8 nicht wieder LTS,
8 ist wieder LTS gewesen, gell, und
7, und 7 war kein LTS,
ich glaub 5 war auch wieder
LTS, aus Prinzip
dagegen stimmen,
vielleicht hast du recht, vielleicht so nicht,
ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt,
ich werde jetzt auch nichts dazu
sagen, weil das beeinflusst
die prediction, ist das
vordere, das wird funktionieren,
ahja, ja, das vordere
wird schon funktionieren,
ihr seid da aber erstaunlich
zu,
ja, zuversichtlich,
ach stimmt, .NET 6 gab's ja
auch, es gab bloß .NET 4 nicht, ja,
ich war grad, ich war grad verwirrt,
.NET 4 würde, das ist auch wieder so eine, so eine
so eine Microsoft-Geschichte, ne?
.NET Core 3.1, .NET 5.
Okay, also die meisten denken, dass es funktioniert.
Okay, ich glaube ehrlich gesagt auch, dass es funktioniert.
Weil, also aus zwei Gründen.
Das läuft ohne Fehler durch.
Normalerweise ist das ja kein guter Indikator für, ob das korrekt ist.
Aber in dem Fall bedeutet es zumindest, der Input stimmt mit dem überein, was ich hier versuche zu parsen.
Was darauf hindeutet, dass es richtig ist.
Weil wenn da irgendwas verkehrt wäre, würde es halt einfach crashen.
Und das zweite ist, dass die Nummer irgendwie, weiß nicht, so bauchgefühlsmäßig ganz gut aussieht.
Es ist jetzt keine 5 oder so.
Und es ist keine 90.000 oder sowas, was zu hoch wäre.
Es ist irgendwas so, wie eine...
...in der Mitte irgendwo.
Und deswegen denke ich mal, dass...
Okay.
Oh shit!
Ey, Moment.
Ne, es stimmt!
Ich dachte, das ist die...
Oh man, Bepega-Time.
Ich dachte, das ist die Meldung so nach dem Motto...
Was steht in der Meldung, wenn es falsch ist?
It is too low oder it is too high, try again oder sowas steht dann da.
Easy.
Wobei, ganz so easy war das gar nicht.
Also das hier ist schon echt pepega.
Aber Leute, bevor ich mich Aufgabe 2 widme,
ich möchte das noch etwas ver-enterpricen, okay?
Wir brauchen noch eine Elf-Game-Factory-Class oder sowas.
Ich würde das nämlich echt gerne noch ein bisschen schöner machen.
Was haltet ihr denn von sowas?
Ja, wir machen sowas wie Public-Class-Game.
So.
Game kriegt int eine ID.
Wo Unit-Tests?
Rewrite in Java.
Ja, in Kotlin könnten wir es...
Ey, das ist wirklich eine gute Idee.
Wir könnten das...
Wir könnten das noch in Kotlin rewriten.
Da wollte ich mich eh mal ein bisschen mehr mit beschäftigen.
So.
Also wir brauchen...
Guck mal.
Ja.
Wir brauchen eine Klasse Game.
Und ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt da sowas wie hier.
Public-Static-Game-Path.
So, und das kriegt dann als Input den String.
Und hier drinnen machen wir das dann.
Gibt's kein Payout.
Ach so.
Doch.
Mod-Modke.
Modke, please.
Payout.
Prediction.
Mod-Modke-Time.
So.
Game-Path.
Dann packen wir nämlich das hier da rein.
Das kommentieren wir mal aus.
Packen wir das hier rein.
So.
Der, der Regex.
Der kommt hier rein.
So.
Wobei, den Regex könnte man eigentlich Static machen.
Aber wurscht.
Der Regex kommt hier rein.
Regex-Matches.
So, und da gibt's jetzt Return.
New Game.
Mit einer...
Ups.
Mit einer ID.
Ah, und jetzt brauchen wir noch...
Jetzt brauchen wir noch für die Anzahl...
Ähm...
Int.
Nennen wir es MaxBlue.
Ups.
MaxBlue.
Blue.
Red.
Green.
Blue ist Result.
Blue.
Red.
Green.
Okay.
Oh, jetzt haben wir das, jetzt haben wir das schon wieder viel nicer ver-Enterprised.
Und jetzt können wir hier oben sagen, wobei, wir können das jetzt wirklich, wir können
das jetzt tatsächlich damit wirklich viel, viel schicker machen.
Wir können jetzt sowas hier sagen wie...
Ähm...
Ja.
Also, Result.
Result.
Result ist immer die, der beste...
Also, Result ist der, der, des Enterprise Naming für Temp.
Ja.
Normalerweise machen sie, aber wenn man nicht weiß, was es ist, immer Result.
Einfach immer Result nennen.
Irgendein Result ist es ja logischerweise, sonst wird's nicht funktionieren.
Welches Result?
Ja, das steht wieder auf dem anderen Blatt.
Also, jetzt sagen wir einfach mal Input.
Select.
Line.
So.
New Game.
Wird das jetzt gepasst?
Äh...
Ne, nicht New Game.
Was mach ich denn hier?
Game.
Pass.
Line.
Und dann können wir sagen...
Ähm...
Wartet mal.
Where.
Ne?
Sowas, sowas in der Richtung.
Where.
Game.
Max Blue ist kleiner...
Wollen wir mal nehmen.
Fangen wir an.
Max Red ist kleiner gleich...
Ja.
Max Green ist kleiner gleich...
Und und.
1.
Max Green ist kleiner gleich...
Ja.
Max Green ist kleiner gleich 13.
Und und.
Max Red ist kleiner gleich...
Wee!
Und.
2.
Max Red ist kleiner gleich 12.
Max Red ist kleiner gleich...
Ja.
Dann Sum.
Das ist auch schon mal deutlich...
pracy .
Moment, Sekunde.
Stimmt ja nicht.
Ja.
Game nur die...
Nur die...
Summe von der ID.
So, ich hoffe da kommt jetzt das gleiche raus.
Das sind es.
hier raus, nachdem ich verenterprisiert
habe.
Shit.
Mist.
Nicht genug verenterprisiert.
Irgendwas,
irgendwo habe ich mich vertippt.
Blue, red,
green.
Oh, blue.
Ey, wir sind tatsächlich noch bei
Tag 2.
Okay, das ist schon besser.
Schon besser.
Was hat er hier?
Convert to group.
Oh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Leute, ich habe noch
eine Idee. Wir verenterprisen das jetzt
noch mehr.
Ich meine,
ich habe eine Idee. Passt mal auf.
Wir machen das jetzt so.
Public
rule
is valid
game.
This, where,
eh, wait a minute.
Ich wollte eigentlich eine Methode
daraus machen.
Valid game.
Kann man das, kann man das,
sag ich so.
Geht das immer noch?
Hey, das funktioniert immer noch.
Okay, business, business
enterprise
improvement ist in Sicht.
Und jetzt, jetzt kommt,
Leute, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt
der, der top
enterprise step
überhaupt.
Das heißt, er rechnet das, er rechnet
das hier.
Jedes Mal aus. Ja, korrekt.
Ja, er rechnet das
jedes Mal aus. Wir könnten das tatsächlich
auch initiaten. Du, du hast, du hast,
du hast recht, du hast recht.
Das ist eigentlich total dumm, was ich hier
mache. Es müsste eigentlich,
müsste sowas hier geben.
Property, bool
is valid.
Du hast vollkommen recht.
Is valid game. Das ist nur
private gesettet werden kann.
Und jetzt wird das, wird,
wird hier gesetzt.
Das wird,
das wird hier, ah, das, das ist jetzt aber
blöd, ne? Da habe ich das noch nicht belegt.
Aber ist ja wurscht.
Game.
Das muss ja auch nicht belegt sein.
Game is valid things.
Klar. Ups.
Return game.
Ja, eigentlich ganz, eigentlich ganz okay.
Ja, das, das, das hat doch, das hat doch was.
Und kommt immer noch das gleiche raus? Ja.
Tatsächlich.
Leute, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Kommando zurück, Kommando zurück.
Pass auf. Enterprise Business Tactics.
Ich habe noch eine bessere Idee.
Pass auf.
Noch, noch eine bessere, noch eine bessere Idee.
Wir lassen, wir lassen, dass das, wir lassen,
dass das eine Methode ist, okay?
Aber, passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
Public
Record
Game Limit
Int Limit Green
Int
Limit Green
Limit Red
Int Limit Blue
Jetzt wird es richtig pfeifert.
Game Limit
So, Limit
Und jetzt, und jetzt, hier.
Limit Red
Limit Green
Ich hoffe, ich schreibe das jetzt nichts verkehrt.
Limit Green und
und Limit Blue
So, und jetzt
können wir sagen,
war Config
gleich,
ne, doch New,
äh, ne, nicht Config, wie habe ich es genannt?
Hier, äh, Limit.
New Game Limit
So, und jetzt mal
Green
12, 13, 14
und jetzt muss es noch richtig heißen,
das erste ist Red.
Ne, wow, ich bin
Red.
Green, Blue.
So, Massive Nice, Enterprise.
Und es kommt immer noch das gleiche raus.
So ist gut, oder?
Jetzt ist es, jetzt ist es Enterprise as fuck.
Jetzt, so kann man das, so kann man das lassen.
So finde ich das gut.
Excellent, excellent, excellent.
Jetzt brauchen wir aber, jetzt brauchen wir eigentlich das hier gar nicht mehr.
Guck mal, jetzt brauchen wir das nicht mehr.
High IQ Refactoring.
Ähm, brauchen wir das?
Ähm, brauchen wir das nicht mehr?
Zu, äh,
ne, äh, Moment.
Kann ich das nicht einfach,
kann ich dem nicht einfach sagen, wandle das
please um?
Naja, egal, meinetwegen, dann
kommt Scheiß drauf, wir lassen es einfach so.
Heiß.
Alles klar, so, ich würde sagen
genug Enterprise Business.
Enterprise gleich umständlich.
Ne, nicht zwangsläufig,
aber meistens auf jeden Fall etwas
mehr bloated.
Rust, vielleicht machen wir auch Rust.
Also,
ich hatte tatsächlich vor, das in Bash zu machen
nachher. Wobei,
wenn ich mir das so recht angucke,
mal gucken, ob da mein, meine,
mein Bash High IQ genug für ist.
Okay, Chat, Frage an euch.
Was,
was fandet ihr schöner lesbar?
Die, die
Enterprise Business Variante?
Oder einfach nur
drei Zeilen, irgendwie nur
zehn Zeilen?
Ich mein, das ist schon ein bisschen aufwendiger geworden, ne?
Also, was, was findet ihr besser?
Das oder
Weiß ja nicht,
ob ich überhaupt, ah fuck, ich komme gar nicht mehr
so weit zurück. Warte mal.
Wartet mal.
Äh, History.
Das oder
ähm, bin gar nicht sicher.
Wo, wo war, wo hat was denn?
Ja, das oder das.
Also, 30 Zeilen
versus Business Enterprise.
Was für einen Maus Cursor
hast du? Das ist
Bibata Modern Ember.
30 Zeilen.
War's auch. War's auch.
Ne, komm, wir lassen es jetzt so. So ist gut.
So ist die Enterprise Business.
Na, wiederverwenden will ich davon ja eigentlich
nix. Wir lassen es jetzt so.
Chat, wir halten uns da nicht so
lang dran auf. Wir lassen es jetzt. Genug.
Genug.
Dokus und Tests, Alter.
Findet ihr nicht,
dass es selbstdokumentierend ist?
Also, also ich, ich find schon,
das ist, das ist so klar
alles geschrieben, das dokumentiert
sich selbst.
Und nachdem es keine Fehler hat, brauchen
wir auch keine Tests. Weil ich will ja,
warum soll ich was, was nicht kaputt ist testen?
Ja.
Ich mein vor allem, wenn es funktioniert.
Ich muss ja nix testen, was funktioniert.
Das ist ja overrated.
Und Kommentare brauchen wir auch nicht,
weil es sich selbst kommentiert.
Okay. Gut. Fertig.
Mit Aufgabe 1.
Weiter geht's.
0, 2, 1.
Ey, Moment.
Okay, Quade.
0, 2.
kommt jetzt. Ich copy-paste mir
das mal, weil ich davon ausgehe, wir brauchen
da bestimmt Teile davon wieder.
0, 2, 2.
New Console. Open.
Nein. So, weil ich das falsche
angeklickt hab jetzt, ey.
0, 2. Okay.
Trust. This window.
So, wir copy-pasten
das rein. Wir kopieren
uns den Text-Output
oder Input
vom alten auch noch hier rein.
Gucken,
ob der Kram hier drinnen auch noch läuft.
Macht er. So, und jetzt
gucken wir uns Aufgabe 2 an.
Aufgabe 2.
Continue Part 2.
Oje. Wat?
Ich ahne Schlimmes, Leute.
Ah.
Ich ahne Schlimmes.
Okay. Also das ist alles
wieder Story-Text,
den man nicht braucht.
As you continue.
In each game you played,
what is the fewest
number of cubes of each
color?
Jetzt. Moment.
Also quasi jetzt.
Ich muss erst mal ganz lesen.
That could have
been in the bag to make the game
possible. What?
Was wollen die von mir?
Was die kleinste Anzahl
an Würfeln
von jeder Farbe ist,
die in der
Tüte sein
könnte? Die kleinste
Anzahl ist, dass die Tüte... Ach so!
To make the game possible.
To make... Ich wollte gerade sagen, meine Tüte könnte halt 0
sein. Seriously, Leute.
Leute, ohne Scheiß. Ich habe gerade
für einen Bruchteil
einer Sekunde geglaubt.
Wir können jetzt einfach schreiben,
ähm,
right line 0.
Ich dachte eigentlich, die wollten
mich gerade verarschen, aber
nein, wollen sie nicht. Okay.
That makes the game possible.
Again, consider the example
games from earlier. Okay.
Game... Was? Moment.
In game 1, the game could have been
played with as few as
4 red, 2
green and 6
blue. What?
If any
color had even one
fewer cube... Ich verstehe nicht,
was die von mir wollen.
Game 2
could have been played with a minimum of
1 red, 3 green
and 4 blue
cubes. 1 red?
Hä?
Ich verstehe nicht mal, was die von mir wollen.
The power of a set
of cubes...
The power of a set of cubes is equal to the
number of red, green and blue cubes
multiplied together.
The power of the minimum set of cubes
in game 1 is...
Okay, okay, okay. Also,
im ersten Spiel bedeutet es
4 mal 2
mal 6.
Ja?
Richtig? Also 8
mal 6 ist 48.
Ja, das stimmt ja auch.
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was die von mir wollen
hier. Ist das wieder viel
Text um nichts? Kann das sein?
Ja?
Ich hab's aber immer noch
nicht verstanden, was die jetzt von mir
wollen. Also ich hab gelesen, dass ihr
geschrieben habt, man kann einfach die höchste Anzahl
zusammenrechnen. Okay, aber... äh
multiplizieren. Aber warum?
Wie kommt man bei dieser Fragestellung
darauf? Ach so!
Moment, Moment,
Moment. Das ist das erste
Game? Das ist das zweite?
Ah, wie kommt... Chat,
wie kommt ihr denn auf die höchste
Anzahl pro Würfel pro
Step? Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, die
wollen die Mindestanzahl der
Würfel haben. Ach so!
Jetzt hab ich's verstanden!
Die Mindestanzahl
der Würfel von jeder Zeile.
Das... Oh Gott, das ist ja
super um die Ecke geschrieben, Alter!
Das ist ja... Das ist absichtlich
das G-Bait, oder?
Das ist ja super um die Ecke geschrieben.
Ich... Ich glaube, jetzt hab ich's verstanden.
Die niedrigste Anzahl der Würfel
von jeder Farbe bedeutet
im Endeffekt, ich muss die
maximale Anzahl der Würfel von
jeder Farbe wieder raussuchen.
Alter, ist das dreimal...
Das... Boah! Das ist... Okay, das ist
absichtlich kompliziert geschrieben.
Das ist... Das ist absichtlich kompliziert
geschrieben, oder?
Was zum Teufel?
Exakt so gucke ich auch. Ich weiß
noch nicht, ob ich der ganzen Sache grad trauen soll.
So scale kriege.
The power of a set of cubes is equal to the number
of red, green and blue cubes... Okay.
Okay.
Heißt... Heißt im Endeffekt...
Nur, dass ich das... Nur, dass ich das jetzt richtig
verstehe.
Wir lassen alles so, wie's ist.
Aber...
Multiplizieren alle Würfel
miteinander.
Also...
Also im Prinzip anstatt dem WHERE
sagen wir einfach hier nur
EXACT
GAME
RED mal GAME
Ich mach das jetzt hauptsächlich auch, weil
der Chat so wirkt, als weiß er, was er schreibt.
Äh...
GREEN und dann...
Ach ne, Moment. Was sollen wir denn jetzt machen?
Adding up these five...
Okay, und jetzt sollen wir den ganzen Krempel hier
summieren am besten halt. Okay.
69. Das kann ja schon mal
nicht falsch sein.
69.629
Verstehe gar nicht.
Und哈...
Am Anfang war das eigentlich auch nur eine Schleife und eine Variable, wo hochgezählt wurde.
Aber mir war das nicht Business Enterprise genug.
Die ursprüngliche Variante hättest du wahrscheinlich auch einfacher verstanden.
Also ich kann es jetzt...
Verdammt, lieber Hund.
Es ist im Prinzip tatsächlich relativ easy, was passiert.
Also wir haben eine Input-Datei mit diesen Zeilen drin.
So, die müssen wir parsen.
Jede Zeile besteht am Anfang aus einer Game-ID.
Und dann verschiedenen Steps mit der Anzahl von Würfeln, die gezogen werden.
Das parsen wir im Endeffekt.
Wir holen uns als erstes aus der Zeile die ID raus.
Dann holen wir uns danach raus, hier mit diesem Magic Regex, quasi immer die Kombination aus 19 Blue, 12 Red, 19 Blue, 2 Green.
Und davon suchen wir uns dann aus der jeweiligen Zeile die höchste Anzahl an blauen Würfeln,
die höchste Anzahl an roten Würfeln und die höchste Anzahl an...
...grünen Würfeln raus, die in dieser Zeile vorkommt.
Ja.
Und das merken wir uns im Endeffekt nur.
Und dann wird überprüft, ob die maximale Anzahl an roten Würfeln kleiner 12 ist,
die maximale Anzahl an grünen Würfeln kleiner 13, die maximale Anzahl an blauen Würfeln kleiner 14.
So, das war Aufgabe 1.
Und in Aufgabe 2 muss ich, soweit es aussieht, nur alle Max-Würfel miteinander multiplizieren.
Nix lieb.
Hier wird nix Debugger-runned.
Als Formel ausgedrückt, rote Würfel Max aus Spiel 1 bis N.
Alles klar.
Malen grüne Würfel Max aus Spiel 1...
Excellent.
Heute Chat wieder besonders viele Prime-Sub-IQ-Punkte gesammelt.
Okay.
Dann testen wir doch mal, ob das funktioniert.
Bam.
Zack.
Submit.
Right answer.
Easy.
Das hätte ich aber ohne Chat diesmal nicht gecheckt, ehrlich gesagt.
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Das hätte ich ohne den Chat jetzt aber echt nicht kapiert.
Eats.
Wie könnte man sowas denn...
Das können wir wegmachen.
Das brauchen wir für das Zweite nicht.
Das können wir auch wegmachen.
Das brauchen wir auch für die zweite Aufgabe nicht.
Okay.
Nice.
Dann committen wir das mal, würde ich sagen.
Git-Status.
Git-Rit.
Hit-Add.
Day 2.
So, dann gucken, ob ich nicht irgendwelche komischen Zeilen...
Line-Endings wieder committet habe irgendwie.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ja, alles gut.
Das fixe ich jetzt nicht.
Dass da unsinnige Whitespaces sind.
Das darf ruhig so bleiben.
Okay.
Day 2.
Nice.
Push.
Git-Push.
Alles klar.
Jetzt mal, ich probiere mal kurz was. Könnte ich den Kram in Bash irgendwie machen? Also ich meine, das ist jetzt zwar hier für Business Enterprise, aber mal drauf geschissen. Das hier ist ja eigentlich erstmal der Kern des Ganzen. Der Rest ist easy.
Also lasst doch mal kurz gucken, ob wir da irgendwie, zumindest vielleicht nicht fertiges, aber irgendeinen Lösungsansatz in Bash hinkriegen würden.
Also, als erstes ist es einfach, also die ID rauszukriegen ist einfach. Das sparen wir uns. Die ID kriegt man im Endeffekt raus mit, so würden wir die ID rauskriegen in Bash.
Okay, das ist schon mal die ID.
Aber um die ID, um die ID mache ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sehr die Gedanken, wie würde ich denn jetzt beispielsweise die Nummern richtig zählen?
Das ist halt echt sowas, wo eine anständige Programmiersprache nicht verkehrt wäre.
Also, die Nummern könnten wir uns irgendwie rausholen hier. E-GREP, GREP kann keine Digits, aber GREP-P kann Digits.
So, wir probieren mal das gleiche wie in .NET.
Blue, Green, ist das gerade ein Hakenkreuz oder so?
Was zum Teufel war das gerade für ein Zeichen, man?
Monka Torsen, Alter.
Was für ein Sonderzeichen habe ich da gerade aus Versehen eingefügt?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Was war das gerade? Hier, ne, ne.
Okay, nochmal Glück gehabt.
Nochmal Glück gehabt, Alter.
Nochmal Glück gehabt.
Wenn man A drückt, kommt dieses Zeichen.
Das sah ein bisschen aus wie ein Hakenkreuz aus dem Augenwinkel, ey.
Monka Torsen, man.
Close.
So, jetzt, so kriege ich die ganzen Dinger raus hier.
Jetzt ist bloß die Frage, wie würde ich jetzt im Bash, weil ich meine, das mit GREP, das mit GREP irgendwie matchen, ist ja das eine.
Okay.
Aber das jetzt extrahieren, ich glaube, da habe ich gerade kein Brain dafür, das in Bash zu machen.
Weil, das Ding ist, wobei, wobei, wobei, wobei, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
GREP kann keine Regax Groups, das ist ja das Ding.
Moment, Moment, Moment, wartet mal, Leute.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Äh, Split, Split, Moment.
Bash, Split, Line, IFS, oh, nee, please.
Ja, mit Cut auf die Idee bin ich auch schon gekommen.
Nee, Leute.
Ja, ja, wie gesagt, das mit IFS geht, das ist mir klar, aber das mir, nee, nee, da, da, da habe ich jetzt echt keinen, keinen Bock drauf, das in Bash zu machen.
Das ist mir zu, zu advanced Shit.
Wir haben, wir haben jetzt die Sharplösung.
Und ich merke auch, dass mein Hirn gerade nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Wir gucken noch mal kurz in Tag 3 rein.
Und, und ich gucke mal.
Ob ich Tag 3 auf Anhieb verstehe.
Dann probieren wir, nee, dann probieren wir vielleicht Tag 3 aus.
Ansonsten lasse ich, lasse ich, lasse ich es sein und mache nachher noch ein bisschen Kreisel-Crime.
Bash wäre noch frei, wirklich?
Es hat noch keiner in Bash gemacht?
Nice.
Dann, dann wird es, dann wird es Zeit.
Dann wird es Zeit.
Okay, was wollen die?
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Okay, what?
Tag 3 ist Pain.
Wenn ich sowas schon sehe, ja.
Also das.
You, you turn around to see a slightly crease.
Bla, bla, bla.
It explains that the engine seems partly missing from the engine.
But nobody can figure out which one.
If you can add up all the parts, all the part numbers.
Also das hier.
It should be easy to work out which part is missing.
The engine.
Consists of a visual representation of the engine.
There are lots of numbers and symbols.
You don't really understand.
But apparently any number.
Neben einem Symbol.
Was?
Any number.
Angrenzend.
An ein Symbol.
Also Symbol sind Punkte, Sternchen und Rauten und, und sonst was.
Oh, Diagonal.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das, das, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Da reicht mein.
Also, ich hätte ja noch gesagt.
Ich hätte ja noch gedacht.
Wenn es, wenn es davor.
Davor.
Okay.
Ich meine, von der Idee her.
Du musst, du musst zählen, wie lang die Zeile ist.
Und dann musst du gucken, ob in der Zeile unten drunter.
Irgendwas steht.
Fuck.
Okay.
Punkte counten nicht als Symbol.
Also bedeutet im Endeffekt.
Die 3 ist okay.
Die 5 ist okay.
Die 7 ist okay.
Ja.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Also hier ist auch wieder die 7 okay.
Hier ist die 4 okay.
Die 6 okay.
Die 5, die 9.
Also diagonal.
Und die 7 hier oben auch.
Ach, die gesamte.
Fuck, das ist nicht nur die Nummer.
Das ist die gesamte Zahl auch noch.
Boah.
Das ist echt eklig.
Oh shit.
Da habe ich keinen Nerv drauf jetzt.
Das mache ich einfach Offstream und tue nächsten Stream.
So als wüsste ich es jetzt.
Rein in Chat GPT.
Ne, das ist ja witzlos.
Indiskematic.
Two numbers are not part numbers because.
Ja, das habe ich schon gecheckt.
Das habe ich gecheckt.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wo ich mein Chat GPT Passwort habe.
Wo ich mein Chat GPT Passwort habe.
Oh fuck.
Habe ich hier gar nicht drin.
Warum nicht?
Jetzt habe ich ein Problem.
Habe ich das bei mir im Handy vielleicht stehen?
Irgendwo?
Wo ich das doch habe.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich mein Chat GPT Passwort habe.
War da schon eine Weile nicht mehr drin eingeloggt.
Ich muss mal Passwort Recovery machen.
Vielleicht finde ich es dann raus.
Wartet mal.
Passwort.
Passwort Recovery.
Change Password for Open AI.
Passwort Recovery for Open AI.
MyEye, Chat, Login.
Login.
Okay, ich bin eingeloggt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob ChatGPD das checkt.
Jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt.
Okay, ich mache euch wieder an.
Ihr seht jetzt gleich wieder was.
Ich habe auch kein Premium hier oder sonst was.
Im Account.
Also, dann checken wir es doch mal.
Okay, Chat.
Ich glaube, das wird nichts.
Ich glaube, hier kann uns ChatGPT nicht helfen.
Ich gehe aber davon aus, wenn man das ChatGPT ordentlich fragen würde,
dann würde es wahrscheinlich das Ganze checken.
Wir können mal was ausprobieren.
Wir lassen mal die zweite Hälfte weg.
Okay.
Ups.
Wir geben ihm nur mal das Erste.
Und jetzt.
What is the number of all of the part numbers in the engine?
Wir geben ihm das hier und dann fragen wir ihn am Ende einfach nur,
what is the sum of all part numbers?
Weil, hier steht ja schon die Antwort drin.
Ich will jetzt, dass er 4361 sagt.
Aber, wie gesagt, ich glaube, das checkt er nicht.
Wir können ihm sagen,
diagonal numbers count as well.
Okay.
Äh, nicht wirklich.
Ich glaube, es macht, ich glaube, das macht keinen Sinn.
The correct answer is.
Tja, ähm.
Das Problem ist.
Ach so, Moment.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Dollar sign.
Diagonal numbers next to the dollar sign.
A35598.
Was?
Nicht wirklich.
Okay, das fand ich.
Da ist Chatgate.
Da müssen wir doch, Chat, da müssen wir doch das nächste Mal selbst, selbst ran, so wie es aussieht.
Das kriege ich heute nicht gebacken.
Jetzt Bart, ne, wobei, muss man sich für Bart einloggen?
Google Bart.
Ich bin doch hier noch mit meinem Fake Account eingeloggt, oder?
Hier, hier.
Pogu Max 152.
Ja, alles klar.
Fake Account.
Es ist Bart.
Try Bart.
Okay, yes, more.
Agreed.
Accreage.
Continue.
Okay, Bart.
Let's go.
Okay, dann fragen wir den hier auch.
Wir machen jetzt hier nicht Example.
Gucken, was Bart erzählt.
Wie ich mir einen Fake Account erstellt habe.
Tja.
Wir haben die letzte Aufgabe schon ohne AI gemacht.
Ich wollte einfach noch gucken.
Oh.
Okay.
Bart steigt komplett aus.
Bart hat gar keinen Bock drauf.
Wir lassen mal das Gelaber weg.
Äh, nein.
Oh, jetzt kommt Python-Stells an den Start hier.
Diagonal Numbers.
Con.
Okay, Bart hat auch keinen Bock.
Dann werden wir das das nächste Mal wohl doch selbst machen müssen, ne?
Na, unabhängig davon, ich hätte es so und so selbst gemacht.
Äh, habe ich jetzt eigentlich gepusht?
Ja.
C++ war schon dran.
Ne, ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich Tag 2 nicht noch in Bash mache.
Aber da reicht meine Gehirn-Kapazität heute echt nicht mehr aus für...
Und Tag 3 sieht schon nach Ultra-Abfuck aus.
Wenn ich es mir schon ansehe überhaupt, ja.
Da habe ich heute echt kein F drauf mehr, ey.
Ich bin heute eh ein bisschen kaputt noch von den letzten Tagen.
Das kriege ich heute nicht hin.
Da würde ich bestimmt jetzt noch mal eineinhalb Stunden für brauchen oder so, wenn überhaupt.
Bis ich das heute hinkriege.
Da warte ich lieber drauf, bis mein Hirn sich ein bisschen beruhigt hat wieder.
Der Chat hat Zeit.
Ja, das kann sein, dass der Chat zeigt.
Ja, das kann sein, dass der Chat zeigt. Ja, das kann sein, dass der Chat zeigt.
Zeit habe ich auch, aber ich habe kein Gehirn mehr heute.
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt eine Runde Kreisel-Crime starten.
Ja, hier ist...
Brain ist Matschke.
Die letzten paar Tage waren zu viel.
Also für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben, meine Katze ist ja gestern gestorben.
Und das war richtig sätge.
Extremely sätge.
Deswegen hatte ich da jetzt nicht so...
Chat, ihr könnt mir mal einen Gefallen tun.
Können wir einmal im Chat...
Für alle Leute, die da sind.
Einmal im Chat.
Ihr wisst, ich bin nicht großartig gläubig.
Darum geht es nicht.
Einmal eine Runde alle im Chat.
Pregge für Chico.
Äh, Chico schreibt man übrigens so.
Chico.
Falls irgendjemand Chico dabei schreiben will.
Eine Runde Pregge, Pregge für Chico, okay?
Exzellent, Chat.
Das ist jetzt doch schon gleich viel besser alles.
Community-Ge.
War zugeschlagen.
Leute am Start, die noch nie was im Chat geschrieben haben jetzt, aber Pregge, Chico, schön, dass ihr alle mitgemacht habt.
Alles klar.
Leute, wir machen heute nicht weiter, mir reicht es für heute.
Ich habe das am Anfang des Streams schon vermutet, dass mein Hirn heute nicht ausreicht, um zwei Aufgaben zu machen.
Aber morgen weiter.
Vielleicht gibt es jetzt gleich noch in einer Stunde oder so ein bisschen weiter Kreiselgrind.
Weil ich muss ja meine Chars weiter leveln.
Guck mal kurz in Discord, vielleicht fange ich auch gleich an.
Nein, nein.
Nicht, wow.
Discord.
Lass mal kurz checken.
Äh, hier ist nix, hier ist auch nix.
Nein, anscheinend nicht.
Ja.
Also ich muss, ich muss meine Hexe ordentlich ausrüsten noch, mein Skaldor ordentlich ausrüsten in Dark und wahrscheinlich noch ein Charmy leveln.
Also wir haben genug Kreiselgrind-Material noch.
Aber nachher.
Ich komm nachher noch.
Ich komm mal an.
Irgendwie eine Stunde oder so, mal gucken.
Und dann Oldschool-MMO-Kreiselgrind.
Finde ich übrigens nice, dass so viele am Start sind da.
Gucken immer so 60, 70 Leute zu.
Was nicht selbstverständlich ist für irgendwie einen 20 Jahre altes Game, man.
Also.
Bis nachher, Leute.
Kreiselgrind startet dann.
Für Programierstells habe ich heute nicht mehr genug Gehirnkapazität.
Wir hören uns nachher.
Und wenn ihr da nicht dabei seid, dann morgen.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.